[Musique]
je crois que c'est intéressant parce
qu'il est dans une phase extrêmement
pourquoi il a donné interview au point
pourquoi il va tf1 et ailleurs parce que
le 10 mai il ya le nouveau procès est le
procès où il perd tous y gagnent tout et
il allait il est installé à quoi perttu
gagne tout c'est vrai vous savez cancer
généralisé depuis quatre ans il sait qui
enfin j'espère qu'il va enfin pourquoi
il vraiment qui est dans ces
considérations actuellement chez vous
des bruneaux parce qu'il veut protéger
sa famille silva pour lui c'est pour sa
famille il se bat aujourd'hui pour sa
famille il est obligé de se battre et
comment il se bat quand il s'est
toujours battu aussi par les médias
alors de se faire des sous ça vous
choque c'est peut-être pas d'accord
énormément c'est n'importe quoi ce que
vous dites andré bercoff c'est à dire
que faire de la violence pour faire de
l'audience
tf1 va quasiment obligé bernard tapie
qui a vient de subir une agression qui
est dans un état de santé extrêmement
difficile
il l'obligé alors qu'il voulait reporter
à venir et parce qu'il est gentil parce
qu'il veut effectivement parlé à vous
connaissez très bien j'ai bien sûr il
veut il veut parler de cette maladie
pour dire il faut la combattre il faut
du courage il voulait reporter on
l'obligent à venir on ne passe pas il a
passé une heure une heure et quart donc
s'ils étaient ils à meyreuil barbie il
serait parti au bout d'un quart d'heure
deuxièmement gilles verdez faut arrêter
comme un devenir n'importe quoi
franchement chaque fois que je viens ici
j'ai affaire à un con comme vous et je
vais vous dire une chose je j'ai un bon
comme vous et je vous dire une chose je
vais le répéter c'est pas très très gai
ce n'est pas très raide raffiné mais je
vous rappelle pierre desproges
il y parle est un con ou et c'est le
convaincre c'est comme se masturber avec
une râpe à fromage ou nos souffrances
pour peu de résultats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on sait qu'il a envie aussi de montrer
qui se bat encore il avait fait jt de
tf1
ouais le 20 heures de tf1 oui je veux
montrer que je suis encore un combattant
même contre ce combat le plus dur que
j'ai dans ma vie et il a dit que
j'allais qu'est ce que c'est bien la vie
c'est un brésilien c'est à résistant au
sens ce ses dires c'est un type me suis
toujours battu toute sa vie le fils de
chauffagiste de de la courneuve etc
il s'est toujours battu ce type battus
en politique ailleurs et il a été battu
aussi combien de fois c'est à dire
regardez moi j'ai le cancer depuis
quatre ans et c'est vrai et je vais vous
dire une chose je ne citerai pas les
gens nous parce que comme on sait que je
le connais depuis longtemps qu'ils vont
demander des micros l'écologie relisant
tapis et non là pour une semaine
vas-y quand j'ai donné ça oui absolument
à plusieurs reprises et j'ai dit à tous
les mois je n'écris pas des nécrologies
de quelqu'un qui est pas mort ça existe
pas et bien jaunir il ya trois ans et
demi il ya deux ans et demi elle a admis
des journaux je ne citerai pas qu'ils
m'ont dit mais oui mezzanine ça y est on
a eu les médecins il en a pour une
semaine eh ben il est là et il est là et
il se bat et c'est ça qui est formidable
chez ce type il s'est toujours battu